the urban environment is a feat of human
decision making
from where to develop street grids lined
with large glass office buildings
to which green spaces to preserve for
outdoor recreation
how humans make these choices and the
natural environment's response
can create extremely different
ecosystems in neighborhoods just a few
blocks away from each other
researchers delved into dozens of
studies to understand what drives these
variations
one well-documented phenomenon in cities
is the relationship between wealth
and biodiversity more affluent areas
generally have greater canopy cover
with larger mature trees as well as a
higher diversity of birds
this is known as the luxury effect
low income areas typically have more
man-made surfaces
including major heat absorbers like
asphalt and concrete
compared to higher income areas
the lack of shade from trees and
vegetation combined with more asphalt
and concrete
makes it hotter in these neighborhoods a
phenomenon known as an urban heat island
these communities are also more likely
to be near sources of air pollutants
like expansive interstates pumping car
exhaust
although wealth can sometimes predict
the outcomes of an urban ecosystem
there isn't always a clear relationship
in some cases the racial makeup of a
neighborhood
is better than income when forecasting
canopy cover
researchers explored studies that
highlighted how systemic racism shaped
our built environment
one glaring example in the united states
is residential segregation
from 1933 to 1968 the federal government
limited access to homeownership among
black americans
through a practice known as redlining
neighborhoods were graded based on the
riskiness of providing a mortgage in the
area
the grades range from a the most
desirable areas full of wealthy
businessmen
to d neighborhoods considered high risk
investments
due to a combination of factors from
their environmental quality and distance
from large industrial factories
to the main determinant the presence of
foreign-born and black people
the inability for black people to buy
homes in these neighborhoods
meant many types of capital investments
left
landlords abandoned their properties and
public services such as transportation
and park maintenance weren't prioritized
today many u.s cities still exhibit
long-lasting environmental impacts from
this discrimination
neighborhoods which had a degrade in the
60s have about half the canopy cover of
historically white communities
some studies evaluate how the current
environment relates to historically
redlined neighborhoods
but researchers did not find any
research that traces how ecosystems
changed over time because of this
segregation
they propose that because habitable
regions are more spread out in these
areas
animal populations struggle to breed
since they are cut off from each other
the reduced breeding options for animals
could have decreased gene diversity
an important way for animals to adapt to
changing environments
and decreased gene flow of native
species could promote the abundance of
pest species
like mosquitoes and brown rats which
carry diseases that can infect humans
the combination of all these outcomes
from urban heat islands to increase
pests make low-income marginalized
communities
far more vulnerable to risks like
climate change
scientists say such evidence shows that
conservation and social justice
cross paths especially along
neighborhood streets
it's